I think actually, so the problem
statement of choosing the most valuable
one, I think is too hard a standard.
So you just want to start a fire, so
if it will burst into flames, it's good.
Now did you hit the perfect place?
If I had started the fire over here,
would it have burned faster and bigger?
Maybe, but I started the fire.
And so that means, how do I recognize
a segment that's not very inflammable.
So, what does wet wood
look like versus dry wood?
And I think a couple of things,
with the target customer,
the key issues are going to be,
is this a target customer I understand?
Do I have access to them, can I
communicate with them clearly, and do
they have the kind of funding or money
necessary to participate with my offer?
Okay, so if you say okay,
I got that, okay.
Then we go to the compelling
reason to buy, and
the key issue there is how compelling
is my compelling reason to buy?
Entrepreneurs have a compelling reason
to sell, so we think our products should
be bought, and we think the compelling
reason to buy is I need your money.
But that's not how a customers thinks,
right?
The customer is thinking, now I'm
going to participate in your offer
because of something I need,
not something you need and so and
then the issue is it, before if
you're just doing it for free, and
a lot of this stuff innitially stars for
free, then you can kind
of be a lot looser because I'm
giving you a few clicks of my life.
Most people are willing to donate
a few clicks of their life.
The third one's then going to be,
does my offer generally scratch
the itch that I said it would.
And so they call it product market fit.
Does my product really, really do this?
I mean I know I want to say it does,
I want them to buy it,
I've said all the right words.
But is that really me,
is that really who we are?
And there you have to be
brutally honest with yourself.
A lot of times you hope it will, and
the market's giving you
a message saying, no, no.
And you're going, yes, yes, no.
Being an entrepreneur is
a very funny state because,
you need to have enough confidence to
hear a bunch of no's and keep going.
But you can't be tone deaf, right?
You have to learn and not just be
stubborn, and that's a bit of a touch.
And then the final one is,
is my offer in this context
truly differentiated enough.
Because when you're starting out,
nobody knows who you are.
So it's not like they're loyal to you.
So you really do have to stand out at
the beginning, or else the world would
go, well why wouldn't I just
go with one of the other guys?